yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Marvel's latest movie Doctor Strange
takes us into a world of dazzling new
dimensions and amazing magical powers
that look truly extraordinary up on the
big screen over the course of the film
director scott derrickson leads us
creatively through a wealth of
exceptionally striking wildly out-there
images of fantastical events and I think
this so he sometimes draws in intriguing
ways on his background as a writer and
director of horror movies like the
consistently creepy sinister in fact for
both the characters and the audience the
movie's visuals and action scenes
frequently blur the lines between waking
nightmare dream and hallucination the
movie manages to literally upend action
genre tropes like one foot chases and
ticking clock scenarios and gives them a
nicely inventive spin to create totally
trippy whacked-out sequences forget your
boring old laws of physics in dr.
strange practically and if it goes
streets buildings walls ceilings floors
and more bend forwards backwards and in
on one another and turn upside down and
twist around in constant motion yes
there are inception and matrix-style
moments but there's so much more than
that Doctor Strange is a wondrous world
of mind-bending movement coupled with a
kaleidoscope of fractured shapes and
colors that send us hurtling through
different dimensions there are even
times in this Steve Ditko inspired
psychedelic world when you actually feel
like you're looking at a moving comic
book page the visuals are so spectacular
and there's so much going on in them at
the same time that it's almost hard to
know where to look in fact it's such a
feast for your eyes that it's a movie
were seeing more than once on the big
screen and just like Jon Favreau's
live-action Jungle Book Doctor Strange
as a movie that really does reap the
rewards of 3d scott derrickson and his
super skilled visual effects teams have
clearly gone all out to make the very
most of that technology and it shows and
on the visual side I've got to give
credit to production designer Charles
wood and the movies art direction and
set decoration teams for creating
beautifully detailed sets including Hong
Kong Street New York homes and Kamata
then of course there's the movies actors
and what a captivating cast Marvel's
managed to assemble for Doctor Strange
obviously we already knew that Benedict
Cumberbatch could play a charming
arrogant genius in a sleep we are
talking after all about the man who
Sherlock Holmes to 21st century life to
such well-deserved critical acclaim and
he does an equally top-notch job as a
self-important neurosurgeon Stephen
strange yes Doctor Strange is a role
that fits Cumberbatch like a glove just
as was the case with Iron Man and Robert
Downey jr. you'll doubtless remember
that there was a good deal of
controversy over the casting of Tilda
Swinton in the role of the ancient one
given the characters an Asian man in the
comics focusing solely on their
performance in the film though Swinton
manages to be ethereal badass and
sharply witty often all at once even
when she's having to explain so much of
the Ruby's mythology Chiwetel Ejiofor
brings poison a certain class the
character of Mordo who studied under the
ancient one and whose function in the
film is too often exposition by tweaking
the comic book role of Christine Palmer
played by Rachel McAdams the movie
quietly acknowledges that if you're a
woman working in a hospital you may
actually be a doctor not a nurse however
the character of Palmer as it's written
isn't particularly scintillating and
it's a testament to the talents of
McAdams that she makes the part work
giving Palmer a level of emotional depth
as the Benedict Wong's character Wong he
gets a welcome makeover from the comics
so instead of being dr. strangers
manservant he's now a steely rule
enforcing librarian at Kumar Taj the
scenes the to Benedict's sure together
are a treat and I'd love to see more of
them just like the rest of the cast Mads
Mikkelsen is an incredible actor but as
the movies baddie Kai Caelius the script
doesn't give him enough opportunity or
on-screen time to connect with us sure
he gets to be part of some cool visually
stunning scenes but in terms of dialogue
and motivation it's pretty thin stuff
having said that where Mickelson does
appear on screen it's still always a
pleasure to see him I just hope his role
in row one is more worthy if it's acting
talents this being a Marvel movie you
can expect a good deal of comedy as is
often the case with any comedy some of
it works while some doesn't land for me
the better comic moments come from the
interaction between the two Benedict's
Tilda Swinton's at times almost
gleefully winking ancient one and dr.
strangers cloak of levitation which is a
playful air of Aladdin's magic carpet
meets baby Groot about it though let's
face it it's hard for anything to outdo
a talking dancing tree as you may have
gathered from everything I said so far
sadly Doctor Strange his script doesn't
live up to the promise of its
spellbinding visual design and its
incredible cast were 14 films into the
all cinematic universe now and I guess
unsurprisingly in some ways dr.
Strange's story feels more than a tad
familiar in fact we've almost come full
circle back to 2008 iron man movie is
this latest film basically follows Tony
Stark's character arc of course is
always a certain amount of been there
done that in any superhero origin story
and perhaps there was a sense among the
script writers and producers that the
outrageously off-kilter reality of this
movies world was more than enough to
make it different or maybe they thought
at that stunningly surreal world that
it's bizarre mythology was already more
than enough for the audience to cope
with without adding further deviations
from the already well-worn origin story
route and to an extent they're right on
both counts
after all the film's dizzying visuals do
make it stand out from Marvel's other
movies and there's so much head spinning
craziness and dr. strangers story that
have been rather a tall order to do what
silver warded so well for Black Panther
and the admittedly already well-known
Spider Man and just plunk strange in the
middle of Avengers infinity war without
giving him a proper feature-length
introduction like this one however with
a stronger more daring script and
derrickson and see Robert Cargill who
worked together on sinister and their
co-writer John Speights Doctor Strange
could have been one of Marvel's very
best movies ever
still this Doctor Strange movie does
show much promise for future outings of
the master of the mystic arts and if
Marvel keeps up this level of i popping
imagery and finesses the scripts were in
for one hell of a trippy ride in later
installments
by the way Doctor Strange is such a
standalone film that you can even enjoy
it without having seen a single Marvel
movie or TV show that said there are
easter eggs and references in there for
fans of Marvel's wider work on the big
screen and in the comic books though
I've gotta say there's been so many
brilliant Stan Lee cameos that this one
kiyah pales somewhat in comparison to
sum up Doctor Strange is a dizzying
dazzling visual delight with stellar
work from the design art costume and
effects departments and the scott
derrickson is capable directions and the
wonderfully accomplished car squeeze the
very most out of the scripts predictable
plotting and reams of exposition Doctor
Strange gets three and a half out of 5
flicks now what did you think of Doctor
Strange have you seen it already
or what are you most looking forward to
about the film and how do you feel it
compares to Marvel's other movies I look
forward to reading your comments below
I've got videos coming up explaining the
post-credits and Doctor Strange and my
full guide to all the movies Easter eggs
click on the links below to check those
out if you enjoyed this video do please
like share and subscribe thanks for
watching and see you next time you'll be
going movie lovers